my name is Mickey tebecca I'm a
developer not a data scientist I'm
working with python for let's say 25
years give or take
um what forever yes
and Python's still alive right python is
32 by the way yeah
I I haven't started that early
um
mostly on the boundary between data
science and production on one side
giving information to data science or
making data accessible on the other side
running models in production and this is
where coming from for this thought apart
for that uh writing books mixing
um video lectures
um and many other geeky things among
them I'm one of the organizers of Pi
data Tel Aviv this is the first
conference so this is the pi data Meetup
and we are going to have a conference a
single day in export Tel Aviv
December 13
ticket sales are on we have a great
agenda we have great guest speakers
coming over so uh you're more than
welcome there's a discount code for uh
uh if you're coming from here uh we're
also looking for sponsors so all the
companies that are saying they're hiring
it's a great opportunity to put your uh
booth in front of 400 people uh and show
the swag that you have
um
okay so enough of the intro
let's start walking and I forgot to
start the timer okay
um so performance when we talk about
performance especially in uh in
conjunction with data science there are
two things when we talk about
performance this is the performance I'm
talking about making things run faster
and making it consume less memory right
the other performance talking about the
performance of the algorithm the metrics
that you choose position we call coin
Kappa whatever you prefer these are not
these ones we're going to talk about
this optimization and why so the first
question is why
why do we want to optimize the code
right
time is a valuable resource okay so time
is available resource but today right we
have Cloud just throw more machines on
it it should be fine
right so cost yeah so when we talk about
uh performance especially in Cloud
environments this is cost right if if
you consume less CPU if you consume less
memory and then you can take machines
which are cost less this is money
all right the second thing that you
mentioned is time and time is not just
time of the algorithm it's also the time
that your researcher is trying to run an
experiment and then maybe another
experiment to maybe another experiment
if each experiment is going to take a
lot of time it will really help the
coffee vendors of the world but I'm not
sure about
um
how people will be satisfied with what
is coming
another reason is viability of of the
code in production right
um Netflix I said I'm all right so
Netflix 2006 uh started Netflix price
which they said here's our data if you
improve our recommendation algorithm by
10 here's a million dollars
this is before kaggle right this is what
started all this idea uh three years
later uh one
team actually if you emerged together
and they won the challenge but the
algorithm itself never made it to
production because it wasn't fast enough
in Netflix
so it's really fun if you find something
which is really
um
again going to the other performance
really interesting performance in The
Matrix but if it's not going to run
production there's no business value you
basically wasted your time
so
one of the things I'm going to try to do
is convince him not to do optimization
by the way
so why shouldn't we optimize
I'm not talking about pre-emization but
right so development time
basically there is a risk right every
time you do an optimization the code is
not that clear
um it's usually more buggy right it's
hard to maintain so when you're taking a
risk every time you're doing an
optimization uh this is uh something
that you uh you need to be really
careful about
um so try to keep this thing in mind
when we're talking about optimization
and coming to solve optimization problem
uh there's actually a lot of data a lot
of knowledge that we need to acquire it
comes from How The Machine Works how the
python Virtual Machine Works how the
networking is working algorithms data
structure how pandas is built in
and very many other things so um we're
not going to go into every one of them
but every time you have an optimization
issue when you uh try to find out you
need to come out with a lot of knowledge
maybe require it as you go along I do it
for a living so I have my bag of tricks
but
um it takes years to to found that one
of the things is how the machine works
and a lot of time when you work with
python right we're with a higher level
we don't think about the machine below
we just you know it's a VM it's funny
but still these things are effective us
so this is computer latency at human
scale so you have the actual latency
which might be different
um these days from when it was published
I think this one was published four or
five years ago but the schedule agency
is about the same so if you're saying
that one CPU cycle is one one second
um
if you are going to so the computer is
organized by CPU it has three level of
caches usually where data is then you
need to go to the main memory and after
that it's going through the disk right
so if you hit the cad if you miss the
caches and you go to the main memory uh
it's about four minutes time meaning uh
the CPU now is going to wait about four
minutes until it gets the data that it
needs to operate even if it's just
increment
if you're unlucky and it's not in memory
we need to go to the disk this is about
17 hours
comparing to a single CPU cycle
meaning that if our data does not sit in
memory if somehow we need to access the
the disk this is a lot of wasted CPU
that can do something else
and if you're going to the network and
Below right this is a very long Network
call right it's across the U.S continent
from
but still uh five years take it to
months even weeks still there's a lot of
fun that the CPU is doing nothing so if
you can optimize at this level and
sometimes we go to these levels in
Python you can even affect how memory is
aligned in memory
um a lot of climate is done but under
the hood with pandas and numpy but it's
still something important
all right so I'm going to switch to uh
show you some code about the data the
data that I'm going to use is coming
from
um the data set you're probably familiar
with this is the New York Taxi data set
just grabbed one file from there
um
and we're going to go so uh
so I'm going to load the load the data
and just to see
we have
three and a half million rows and we
have several columns in our data set
that's that's roughly what we have and
this is what I'm going to play with and
because there's something with the
screen you're going to see my cheat
sheet all the time
um so um
we are going to start actually uh
with the rules of optimization Club
okay and the role optimization Cloud
said you do not optimize the first thing
is uh
python is fast enough the developers of
python writing low level C so it makes
faster they developer pandas thinking a
lot about algorithms data structure due
to python so you do not optimize
the second one is the one that is really
interesting
you do not optimize without measuring
first
and I see two things here one is how do
you know that we're fast enough
we need a number right we need to know
that processing
the
a day's worth of data should take less
than
an hour a minute a second whatever
in my experience getting these numbers
from the stakeholders business or
production it's really really hard
but you can't go without them because if
you don't have these numbers then you
just optimize for fun right because it
doesn't have a business value once once
you know these numbers now you can start
measuring and say okay I'm hitting the
Target or not and always make sure to
have the
business people understand that you're
not going to hit the number all the time
right now the percentile is going to do
with 99 of the time 99.9
Etc and every nine is a lot of effort to
do
okay
um what happens a lot of fun uh when I'm
doing it people are telling me do it as
fast as you can
right and my answer is usually okay you
give me a hardware team in two years
we'll be there
um this is usually not available and
then we start doing some negotiations
about what can be done and how we can do
it so you need to get these numbers uh I
I a little time and I start with saying
is minute okay is a millisecond okay by
the way a lot of time it's going to
affect the design of the system if
you're doing fraud and the requirement
is that once you detected some anomaly
uh you say the client should be notified
in an hour in a day in a minute or in a
second these are three different systems
you're going to do so there is a lot of
importance to these numbers
the second thing about measuring is to
know where your code is spending the
time this is known as profiling we will
see an example
in a bit but the idea is that you never
guess
every time that you're going to think
yes my code is going to spend time there
um from my experience and I'm doing it
as I said 20 something years 50 of the
time I'm wrong I'm doing a web
optimization because my there's a bad
gift so I'm never guessing I'm running
the profile I'm looking at where the
code is spending the time in only then
starting to access things
is
okay
um
number three talks about the external
factors going back to the previous slide
about how much time uh things are taking
so if most of the time is spend on this
style or network this is not a
code problem and then uh unit test this
is the risk that you're taking
I'll skip over the rest
okay so one thing is uh in IPython or
Jupiter we have these Magics right so
these Magics start with a percent
and there are two interesting Magics
that we can look about one is the time
magic that gives us just a single time
of
um housing run so this is a pocket let's
say that the
I want to read a CSV file
um
oh
thank you very much okay so for example
and this is one thing that might affect
your code if you reading from files the
bracket is 318 and always not the units
right 18 milliseconds versus
3.91 seconds or about 10 times faster
faster to load the same data set just
because of the file right I hate csvs
with a passion if you want to talk about
it later in
um come and come and take me out a lot
of them thought about the CSV in general
and
the second thing that we have is known
as timings uh if I'm going to do a total
amount but some this is going now to run
the same code in the in this case it did
seven runs a hundred Loops each and
reports uh both the time the other the
mean time the average time and the
standard deviation
okay so uh this is something that you
can run these two Magics and depending
on what you're trying to do most of the
time if it's short Snippets of code that
run fast you're going to use time it is
more accurate but sometimes especially
when loading um
you want to do more than that
if you have more than one line of code
that you want to run the Magics in I in
Jupiter actually can come with a single
percent sign these are known as line
Magics or with a two percent signs and
these are cell Matrix and now it's going
to measure what happens inside the whole
cell
right so um you can even if you want to
have a bit of code check out and see how
it's working and what it's doing for you
and the last one that is interesting is
the prawn so the the piran uh
okay uh hold on scrolling is not mine
okay uh so now you can see it right so
the pron Peron is a profile run this is
using the built-in python profiler
uh and generate reports about where is
spending the data and we talk about
profilers we can we talk about two kinds
of profilers the one that we have in the
standard library is what is known as an
event based profile it gets information
from the python virtual machine started
the function exit the function enter a
function X the function and then you you
have a full view of what's going on
there are two disadvantages to this
profile one the granularity is a
function right so if you have a big
function a lot of time in Jupiter cells
and other things we write the big chunk
of God even though we shouldn't
um
we won't see what's going on there the
second thing is that the overhead on
runtime is bigger
in outside the standard profiler
projects like Pi spy and others they are
sampling based profilers like we've said
the same idea there's something that
wakes up every amount of time ask python
where are we now and at the end
generates a report assuming sampling is
fast enough you are going to get
inaccurate
um
breathing of what's going on
uh when we see puron you're going to see
that the it gets us actually two three
three one is the number of calls for the
function the second is the total time in
perical time and the community final so
the total time is just the time spent
inside the function commodity time is
the function and all this function it
also called all the culture is behind it
to see that so a lot of time when you're
interested in profiling what you're
looking at is
um the cumulative time
you can do it in the
in that in the same one again and then
you can see and
not sure how many people guess that get
item from the frame is
the number one issue here in the code
and more than other things
okay there are other tools like snack
fees and others that will give you a
visual
look at the how we're recording spending
the time and they might be more
interesting uh to look at
I'm old school
I'm using mostly this
okay
um
so this is our code right
um it's doing a for Loop and basically
when we're talking about optimization
and pandas follow-up is the enemy
we try to avoid for Loop and we try to
do vectorization as much as we can and
we just if you're going to do the same
operation
um
in a in a group I this is going to be
about 10 times faster a bit more
okay so always try to vectorize whatever
you can sometimes you can right but this
is one of the things that we would like
to look at
whether if you have questions feel free
to ask them
yeah
another question I know there is a tour
maybe quite new memory it's like a
memory profiler yes
yes so so there are uh tools that are
built-in Linux Prof and other tools that
they know how to track system calls and
others uh there's so many profiles out
there really uh
uh just try them out see what they say
whichever works for you but yes some of
them tracking system calls a lot of time
if your call is spending time on let's
say uh waiting for a lock threading lock
to release or maybe another this is not
going to be so obvious in in other
profilers and then you need to look at
system calls and other things as well so
yes
um
um
what did they do wrong now
oh I need just this one so I'm just
taking uh the first 10 000 rows
and then I'm doing a for loop with the
eater rows and this is one of the worst
thing you can do in Canada pandas is
column oriented it's not built for us it
need to build a row every time you ask
for it this needs to go to the column
select the values and get it there and
this is usually uh very slow
um if you're going to uh
do the same in a vectorized way this is
going to be much faster right again note
the units
all right so these are 110 milliseconds
which are
100 uh
yes I'm here uh oh okay that's the fact
that python has underscore
so 319 times faster if you're doing that
so every time you see something that is
doing iteration of the rows that's one
thing that is for sure killing your
performance and you should try and look
at the something else
another thing that we can look about
look on is using functions okay so this
is the built-in python Max which I'm
running on
the total amount and this is
one way we can do it right the other way
we can do it
is called the Max from pandas
but the more time
it runs it's better it's also great in
the winter it really hits up your
machine
um
so
again we're going faster
we can also call the numpy right so if
you do dot values you extract the
underlying numpy array and then you can
call the max function
um
and then it's even faster
okay so knowing and this is what I
talked about knowing how the python VM
Works versus pandas versus numpy and
who's faster and who's better this is
always a thing to remember
there is a price to pay by the way
um
so
if I'm doing this I'm going to get the
sum
if I'm doing this
this is not right there is a big
difference between numpy seeing Nan as
an invalid calculation and once it gets
there it's
not working versus pandas with seeing
Nan as a missing value and then it just
ignores it so you need to be aware you
gain performance but the behavior might
be a little bit different than what
you're thinking you're going to do so
when you compare now yes
now so when you do some calculation like
Sam or Max I mean and there is a man in
in the middle a path is just going to
ignore it saying it's missing value I
don't care and not by saying okay I
reached to something which is not a wide
calculation I'm stopping here I'm
returning an N that's it now there is a
nan sum and then Max in numpy that you
can do all this operation telling it to
ignore an ants but you need to be aware
of that if you're doing it every like
this it might be a mission
yes oh
um yes
um
uh DF
oh maybe there's not Max yeah there is
well uh
this is what I like walking with Jupiter
right Python and all these questions
just write down and you will get an
answer
now Max is his number is numpy's version
of of doing operations ignoring dance
like like panda is behaving so it's
roughly the same like the um it's faster
than the pandas one uh by the way you
need to remember that in pandas we have
several types of missing values not just
nands right not the time there's the the
integer uh new integer which is n a you
know and several other ones
um
so we need to look at this
um
uh this is not going to okay another
thing we want to look at is a memory
okay so
um
the data frame has memory usage
right this is going to give you how much
memory usage I Define the megabyte so
um our data frame is
um
taking far about half a gigabyte right
um
if you look on disk right this is taking
way less
uh from from what we get inside there
um in memory pandas is really wasteful
in memory
then the CSV is compressed so
make it I don't know
seven times bigger but it's still not
not the the them
what
um
yeah
you think did you see on text my
experience is 30 but
maybe it's better now I don't know I
think Bishop is better not sure
okay so how can we avoid all of this one
is uh
you know uh
we can just load what we need we don't
need to load everything into memory and
in parquet and databases this is much
much easier
come on
we have less than water
so this is one thing you can do you know
don't
it's really easy right with C3 with
pocket boom everything goes to memory
but sometimes hey I just need these two
to work with them so I can reduce the
memory
uh another thing you can do
um
um
foreign
so we can look at the total amount right
but if you look at the total amount a
little bit better
described we can see that the values
are between
um
minus I always don't I never get them
wrong right right so I just again
between
um
and if you like if you look at the
D type it is float64 right
so float64 can hold
way more values than that and if you're
going to use flow 30 not floated 34 52.
it is still in the range of the numbers
that we want
right so uh
yeah floor 16 I think the problem
that you can use but it's not native to
the hardware so most Hardware is
yeah it has that but I think the
hardware is going to struggle with 416
it's so ancient uh
really okay so maybe uh right so floor
16 will get us even better
um
yeah uh yeah this should be fine as well
so pick the data types right sometimes
when you load the data from them uh from
pocket it's already has a specific data
type when you loading from CSV you can
give the types to the read CSV and it
will help you with that
um
okay let's say we want to to gather
names uh so we have these names and now
uh we want to assign to the vendor the
name the actual name of there
right so we can use the apply
with the Lambda
but
we don't need a Lambda
right we can just pass in the get method
um function calls in Python are
expensive
so every time you can reduce that and
names.get is actually written in C so
yeah
we're getting better
and
we can get even better with
blue
all right good names
all right so uh if you're doing your
name uh
we're getting to 34 milliseconds versus
the initial at one
right so seven times faster again
understanding how pandas work and what's
going on
if you look at the memory usage of
[Music]
the vendor
um
oh the vendor ID they're going to be
about the same which is interesting
right because one is a string
one is a number they shouldn't take the
same thing uh
and once you do DP equal true meaning
telling pandas not just look at the
pointers but go all the way you will see
the big difference between them
so we gaining readability we're losing a
memory we would like to fix that
so one of the solutions that pandas
gives us is what is known as categorical
types if you don't have a lot of types
in there
um
that is type
cut the glory
and now uh if you look at the memory
usage it's actually better than the
integer
right because it's encoding it's doing
like a hot encoding recording the
numbers and saying them and now we get
actually the best of both world it's
consuming less memory and the comparison
if you're doing compression actually
comparison between each other they're
not uh
equal strings uh and other things
um
okay so this is the taste of the things
that I'm doing when optimizing pandas to
know where but you first need to start
with
[Music]
um
measuring and getting the goals
now the thing that is going to affect
the most Euro team or your company is if
it's in the culture once people start
talking about optimization maybe using a
pie test Benchmark to publish benchmarks
for running the algorithm and showing
them when doing code reviews and saying
is this the base data structure for that
what is the requirement of performance
for this one and can you do as a company
can you tell me that 15 increase or
better Precision is worth five percent
decrease in performance
can you do that most companies that I
work with
um they can't they don't know right so
think about performance talk about that
you don't need to know all the
algorithms and data structure but once
you start thinking about them the
internet is there stuck overflow is
there there's many many things that you
can do
um
so thank you I have two classes in
LinkedIn learning one is called faster
panels which this is part of it and
faster python code hit me on LinkedIn
and I'll give you a free
[Music]
if we possible to watch them if you want
to
um
questions yes thank you very much
interesting uh just a remark about
teacher Rose yes
yes
okay I haven't tried it yeah I most of
the time that I had problem with etheros
I managed to to actually do some kind of
uh apply with the access equal one and
usually it's good enough
more questions
thank you oh yeah that's a question more
like comments and you didn't elaborate
enough about external tools to actually
do dependence I can name a few pageant
to a Bodo uh a book deal if you do
things paralyzed oh so so there are
several alternate data frames uh that
that are in play
um the the most I think the most
famous let's call it is dusk which can
parallelize automatically paralyzed a
lot of computation
um and there's view there's not in the
there's several others there are very
interesting some use cases they are
better the problem with all of them uh
there's actually also who DF coming from
Nvidia running calculation on the GPU in
the the problem with all of them they're
not 100 compatible to candles there's
always something that is missing for
example uh in in dusk because it
paralyze everything you don't have a
median function
mean is easy to do in parlor medium
not so much so uh if you have a specific
use case and maybe one of these are
helping you
maybe yes but I usually uh try them and
then I found out that most of the time
is just something is missing and then
it's not working
yes
you try to measure the time in high spot
for the same class
this is moving from in the machine on a
single machine same memory space to
something that is paralyzed so by spot
once you run out of uh all of these
tricks and you need to move to Modern
single machine to process the data then
two such as price spark desk and and
others are the option but you can still
embed some profiling information inside
of them there's a way to run the
profiler and the timer inside
um the running code and just publish it
as metrics
if you do that go and read about
monotonic clocks yeah just to make sure
that you're doing a measurement
yes first of all thanks sometimes it is
fascinating
um could you elaborate more about
um
to apply with access.1 does it not
create a role for each no
I don't think so I'm not sure I'm not
that expert on the internals of pandas I
don't think it does that I think it just
goes for every column and then doing
something I'm not sure
um actually it's a good question uh
I don't know that my answer is
yes
when you try to come
up yeah
yes
and and when you when you manage to do
that
um
it's usually a lot of times faster than
doing a follow-up editorials maybe just
the way that pandas is running faster
than python followed I don't know
um I need to check it out that's that's
a good question
not necessary but you need to you need
to check it out there are other tools
like um
digit compiler number and sometimes even
writing code in siphon which can also
help with that but this is a path I
usually
leave for for last result
it doesn't always help no it doesn't
always say no
don't number all the things it's not
entered
any special tips about indexing like you
know sometimes if you store things
the only thing that comes to mind is
that I know that join data frame by
index is usually faster than generating
by specific columns apart from that I
don't have anything specific to indexing
I think join is only by index emerges
yes
okay so thank you very much
[Applause]